okay so yesterday we you're doing you're
doing the out this is actually the
outward spiral okay my hand although my
elbows going in that our spiral is is
going to go that way so for example
getting y'all concept if the technique
overall is yielding there's got to be a
little bit of young into it so as the
technique is the outer spiral there's
going to be a little inward spiral to it
do you understand so the hip was going
in and the elbow was going down okay
now let's work on the inner spiral and
you can just reverse all that so even
though the spiral is going in the first
move is the hips can go back and the
elbow will go up okay
so again you'll follow the same rules
that the elbow is going to stay in a
kind of graceful pattern with no zigzags
and no lines across the circumference or
the radius do you know you're not doing
this kind of stuff keep your grip please
you're not doing this do you see that so
here my elbow one is straight back then
straight up and then turn this is too
jagged see that no okay also you will
not change the relationship between your
elbow and your ribcage got it so when
you did that when I did that last one
you see I just shrunk that area okay so
we're here like this and drill one is
I'm going to continue this freeing of
the one corner so I'm gonna free that
corner it's gonna go back that's the
beginning
oh okay let me push it hard here
so going back to the outer spiral title
head coat so when he's pushing remember
I I'm not moving him
I just free the corner and drop the
elbow read the corner drunk down read
the corner drop the elbow that is on
line two
he's pushing right then I'm just doing
that line thing so when you're here do
not move him do not move him you see
that difference you'll note it in your
elbow the elbow now change distance DC
so I'm not trying to move him so I don't
need to pull him I don't need to yield
to him I don't need to push yeah I'm
just here I keep this relationship he
pushes and I just do this free let's
take the elbow turn out just a corner
here
see did you were gonna feel it in your
outer dough
question here
HR
so it looks different what you're doing
but you don't know that but to me to my
eye it looks different so I'll show you
some things you can do okay so what it
looks like you're doing is more hip
rotation shoulder rotation and that's
why you get the pull okay so for example
Leah you're gonna come up you can test
for certain pressures okay so as he
pushes at just some of them as he pushes
right and I turn my hips like this okay
you can see that I'm disjointed okay so
when Leah comes to push on this hand
let's just push on this vector right up
my arm right up my arm it's very
difficult to hold it it'll be nearly
impossible for her to for me to keep it
up so she pushes down
okay and that upward miss is important
because remember that I'm going to turn
my elbow around this way okay so when I
go here he cannot stop me from lifting
that half push down so technique if I go
here and we should sound because that
from that elbow out you see but if I go
here this hand becomes liftable so why
because I come in off on his stuff side
you see I'm coming in on this look how
awkward that is for pushing down
something you wouldn't do that you would
you would want to push down here
so when you turn your body and then you
turn to help us down you get - and
that's exactly what needs to push down
which is what you guys get a lot of when
you do it wrong do wrong because that's
a unit you see so I can't do that so I
just same way things smaller smaller
smaller not okay very small and I turn
my elbow
and since he's never really on it my
arms can be relaxed all I have to do is
always feel for his Center maintain zero
pressure I'm not on the positive or the
negative side and then move from my
centers
kind of shrink everything but you can't
just shove into it hey let's try so you
are not simply changing his skeletal
alignment see so I asked him okay
and then I do stuff with his arm and so
I could get away with these kind of
shapes you see that so you know like but
that's not the sound that's not
mechanically sound you can feel it if
you're honest and you're all going in
your tricep also it's not tactically
sound because the guy had and a bulldog
hold on to you in order for you to do
that okay so kind of like yesterday's
training in some way his basic support
is being immobilized or taken away from
his control so that when I create the
angle of disturbance he can not so
readily regain his balance okay so in
this technique he was tasked with the
initial push so he's coming forward I'm
gonna keep that going full
because a little forward and then my
idle disturbance line cuts here okay so
he's going forward and I push I am NOT
going to when I'd go like SEC he's not
coming full he's going up you see and
then I'm doing this well what if he let
go and just come in now you're whole lot
of okay so you wanted to keep going
forward so this movement you see he's
going forward but I'm going to turn it
I'm gonna make it go to this side and my
projection then has to be of such a
nature that does not stop him from going
forward so you are not going like this
and you push them back down you see you
have to go I do feel the center but I
have to go over the top of it both
vectors ours is not that he needs to
travel but his inertia needs to be on
that vector
do you understand so he's pushing really
hard right and you see how he's coming
in that
so there's energy there I don't let it
go that far but I need to make sure it
keeps going that way that he's tasked
with that inertia then as I throw back I
can't not push him back and stop that
backer okay so it's just over the top
it doesn't it's not a matter of you
actually aiming over this hop and nor
was it a matter of you pulling him into
them it's just energies going this way
and that Energy's gone over this mother
okay this is why you can make these very
small you can keep it vague
[Music]
again in your lust for power in your
life I go like that
you see I've lost the power always you
prioritize the hand you prioritizing the
visible role so you're like I can see my
hand go right it's not it's not in this
it's not just about a where you're
touching you understand that it doesn't
matter where where or with what you're
touching see it's just it's just energy
even the pattern I gave you is not not
important your push right not important
you see
so wherever I'm not it's just the
pattern so you see how you guys will go
like this so you're like oh now you're
not doing it so I had a point
what I feel is I feel is the initial
pressure it goes off when I turn like
that easy and then before he crashes
into me I start to turn deflect it that
way he's energy that way you see and
then I just need a vector over here so
it generally happens where everything
else happens here not here here so as I
come around boom he hits top you see he
hits it and that reaction is the vector
do you understand I'm not shoving him he
hits the vector won't oh right
it said do you understand so I achieved
my shape and I keep relaxed
[Music]
you guys are loading your hat okay
Charlie okay let's take the mistake I
pointed out where someone is going to
use the kind of elbow to to tweak his
skeletal line okay in some ways it's
right which is why people do it because
it was a plausible near mistake okay so
they're here and they realize that the
forearm can be a contact point but
they're thinking skeletal alignment I'm
going to have the forearm be a point but
it's this pressure here so I'm gonna do
agency on the vector and you'll see I
can push him with that point where he's
alleging on me you see that you get it
okay they were using that point to
skeletally torque his elbow and shoulder
mechanism okay I am here and then I can
push on that point but that would not be
Aikido and not this technique so what
I'm doing instead is his energy is
coming in
and when it comes forward it hits that
point do you understand
so versus me generating the energy i
generate stability he hinted at a
deflection of the deflecting angle and
it makes him go over okay which means
now I don't have to anything you get it
which means what's more important is the
yin moment the Ian moment is what gets
him on the initial needed vector making
max lighter and then has him hit my
stability okay so this is this is
different you see that this was him
hitting me he hits me maybe if you think
of it
[Applause]
[Music]
and I am now actually completing the
inward spiral when you do the other one
it's a usual
this way in-out in-out
so if because I'm operating at an
energetic level the more energy he gives
me the easier everything is meaning the
more mouths will go into the forward
progress right that vector so that means
there's less mouths I wanna do the
projection point and the more energy he
gives me when he rebounds off of the
ledge there's going to be more rebound
but when I don't have things set up more
energy actually leads to energy escaping
out of that system and then I don't have
and so you'll see a breakdown of the
mechanics you were just trying to get
okay so I can you can already see that
this parts not engaged so if you paid
attention his knees wobbled because he
got lifted because I I gave full
pressure here just did you feel that so
you can already tell this is not going
to work right and you can see that this
collapse so once he starts the movement
and he frees the hip is too much energy
is too much energy
okay so he will resort to that we see
that he's resorting to the shoulder if
you could maybe hear his shoulders
because he's overstressing it right do
you get what I'm saying
okay so he didn't have the right
anatomical organization and then they
will resort to the attacker defender
mindset you'll use your external muscles
and then you can't do the technique okay
and this time so you guys can see I want
you to note what the where the
organization breaks down so I go and we
add the down the down right and again
attention your shoulder kinked up so I'm
not pushing all that hard you see but I
will fill the hidden spaces that her
technique is created so what happened to
me did you see I went off balance and
then what went back on the switch is
actually giving me back my balance okay
Tim did you see that elbow came up like
this it's outside of frame
and again it's not very hard but I can
already see you extending like this you
see that you already don't want me leave
now so you all you came in with the
attacker defender of dichotomy do you
understand anything okay so we go and
then you're going to lose that one right
why because your levers in the wrong
place so you and now as you turn it down
when you try to push me out you actually
put me at a disability and I have them
accounted for damage okay so you're
still pushing me out do you understand
so so what I moved
so I hear all the time
don't I don't have enough energy
you can you push that now but I'm not
doing this
I just need me for
together difference already so it's
still
so how how much forward has look look at
don't don't
I want you to just forget Jerry's dad
there you go get so you can see there's
forward there's forward into good then
you see and now when you go the private
life counter can't you see
go there again
you guys see that collapse which way is
it supposed to go is this your out yeah
cuz because do you feel the push and you
feel yourself stopping it okay so that
would be your money off and it'll work
if you're stronger than me if I don't
have a knife it'll work if there's not
another attacker and you're strong okay
but once you what you're feeling here is
well now you're yielding but you can see
that so here anything's yeah cat I can't
come in you're stopping me from coming
in if you see that say that so again if
I had a knife your PIN is you pushed me
out in between yourself if there's a
multiple attackers your PIN they're
gonna get you if I'm stronger than you
which I am in this case it's going to
push you over do you understand do you
guys get done okay so what'd she do she
did a beginner correction who can spot
it it was already there it's already
here she scooted back these seizures
like it was too much push I'm gonna
scoop that but now we're not training on
the yen absorption so come back because
you got
start of the technique right okay so we
go and then we have that crooked s s
spying game and then she's trying to
pick it up do you see that but can I am
I able to go forward no you feel me push
pushing on me right that's you stopping
me so now I have perfect balance I have
perfect balance I can move however I
want if you if you let that arm go dead
then I would lose my balance together
okay so
so where did when TC he shoved me back
okay so you go on like this you want I
need you to come this
Oh
[Music]
don't do anything for push
so you are a mixture of super light and
super faith
I'm going to be heavier and not fake I'm
pushing
since you see there's not you don't have
the young capacity to not utilize the
initial vector huh
do you guys understand that if I sit
here and I go heavier than you but faith
right and you go okay I was assigned the
task which was push but she there's no
source in DC which is why my push gets
your Center okay that was an external
elbow absorption do you see that same
thing which is a gig space in correct
organization that was you on it again so
that's the trick a local floor that Luke
is ready look at this
yeah I'll show you how fraudulent tax
okay yeah right let's go
do you see how you solving for the
elbows
okay look for 100 where do you want my
push down push down on it
push try to knock me down push down so
how much more go okay yes feel the
yangtze give me there
okay so as you guys what I'm trying to
show you is you're too satisfied with
your weekend falling down don't forget
if they fall or not keep the pattern
keep the energetic requirements got it
because when you get satisfied with them
falling you probably aren't doing the
other two things okay let's go
so what I see is that you you stop your
bull your role is just to push him knock
her down your role is to do linear
thrusts that way that way she has a
conflict that way she can practice
reconciliation but what happens is just
do it normal okay you you'll push to
there and now all of a sudden you go
into Kimmy mode you see that and then we
don't want that we're so low you're not
gonna get hurt if she actually took your
balance and locked you down
do you understand okay so you're gonna
put all your effort all the muscles is
what I want you to play okay good and
you're gonna do your technique you're
not gonna shove it you're gonna do you
go so you can see that elbow is coming
out push hard push hard and try to fix
it try to fix it try to fix it fix it
better and you went though into Kimmy
push hard with your Center you going to
Kenya you're sharpening her not though
your elbows come to stay in now okay oh
there goes out okay so so
you can say how much muscle your body
and what I was demonstrating was if I
just keep the singular intention do you
see it will fall in well now she's
trying to muscle me back do you get it
did you feel that watch the pressure
increase you see pressures there nice so
it's not it's not about something it's
just about stay focused on your singular
assigned intention okay so I was never
allowed to come forward this is all the
forward you given me you see now I'm
stuck here so how far off do I need
I can't blend will that work when will
that work when you're stronger than me
right but it but it's not Aikido so if
you're not stronger than me then you
give me the ledge that I use to push you
you want to reconcile this it is not
reconcile stay there so this is where
you felt that one cuz the elbow came out
okay but what happens is going you feel
her pushing on you you go like that and
then you follow it in and then you don't
follow it in keep going
what's the worst that happens I'm alive
it's not that I fall fine don't start
pulling out a technique that's not
trying to get you to do your intention
should be full coming in that way
her job is not this you see that that's
not it this is going to be external
mechanically disadvantageous this
I need you to push
[Music]
cuz you felt young young right but I am
holy
so you go like this what was my singular
intention forward
let's do you again know how many Texas
is right this is eungyeong right am i
still push you down forward yes I am
what's the difference see that's - okay
so when you came up and you put down on
that instead of forward on it did we
change the technique but I don't want
you to do that
[Music]
good why'd they do that to test whether
you keep in the singular intention
and now start accepting it that there's
the trainees okay you just release Excel
please accept no no attention no
intention yeah I didn't rillette go on
calm down good that's it you see how the
more immediate her overtake the
committee was on the last round
okay yeah